hi I'm Erik Bosse and there are a lot of
things we love about Rick and Morty the
unapologetically dark humor the complex
storytelling and you may know that
creator Justin roiland loosely based
e-series on his animated shorts doc and
Marty but what were these shorts all
about I am gonna break down the DNA of
the current day Rick and Morty and
discuss how those simple crude shorts
actually evolved into the subversive
humor we see on the show today okay so a
little background justin roiland came to
know dan harmon through channel 101 a
monthly indie film festival in Los
Angeles that Harmon co-created with Rob
Straub way it works is filmmakers submit
five-minute pilots and the audience
votes on which series gets second
episodes it's free and it's super fun
the shorts range from elaborate prop
spectacles to super filthy cartoons in
2006 justin roiland created a series
called House of Cosby's it was a sitcom
featuring a bunch of Bill Cosby clones
now Bill Cosby's lawyers actually sent
roylene cease and desist letters so as a
sort of jokey protest roylene created
the real animated adventures of doc and
Marty with these crude animated versions
of the characters from Back to the
Future now you can watch the pilot
online warning it is super tough it's
basically five minutes of Marty
performing fellatio on Doc now it didn't
make it to a second episode but the
characters of doc and Marty kept
reappearing in other channel 101 shorts
and the voices that were linked created
for them became kind of a beloved inside
joke and whole community so
fast-forwarding to 2012 Dan Harmon was
fired from the show community and Adult
Swim approached him to make a new
animated show so he approached royland
and they adapted doc and Marty into Rick
and Morty Rowland later said he was
actually worried Adult Swim would see
the original Puerto graphic short on
line but that wasn't an issue and the
show became a huge success now even if
Adult Swim did see it I would argue that
twisted sense of humor ended up becoming
a key component in why Rick and Morty is
so beloved by fans so let's break down
all the ways these shorts foreshadowed
the show that Rick and Morty would
become and let's start with the general
concept now I obviously love this show
and I've spent a lot of time thinking
about what makes its humor different
from
other great animated comedies like
Futurama or The Simpsons South Park or
Bojack horseman and I think the core
element that makes Rick and Morty unique
is the way that it consistently subverts
complex sci-fi concepts with simple dumb
gags Rick and Morty is set in a world
where technology has made anything
possible so the humor comes from Rick
and the others doing the most petty
brainless things with that technology so
just like Doc and Marty go back in time
to prevent a tree from getting planted
so that Marty's kite won't get stuck in
it Rick sends Morty on a dangerous side
adventure to retrieve kalaxian crystals
and Rick see business just to get a
little high during the party and Rick
sells an antimatter gun to a deadly
assassin simply to blow all the money in
the blips and shit's arcade there you go
3,000 floor bows you understand what two
humans can accomplish with 3000 of these
Oh what an entire afternoon at blips
inches Rick takes Morty and summer to a
spider universe because it has the best
ice cream it's got giant telepathic
spiders 11 9 11 and the best ice cream
in the multiverse we also see this idea
with the interdimensional cable box
where the show spent two episodes just
surfing TV programming from other
dimensions and Rick inventing a robot
for the sole purpose of passing the
butter what is my purpose you pass
butter oh my god but yeah let's be
honest Rick and Morty doesn't shy away
from using a good old dick joke to
undercut these sci-fi themes as well we
even added a whole section to our
breakdowns just to point out each
episodes hidden Dickey's so just like
how marty has to perform oral sex on da
characters and Rick and Morty frequently
have to sexually demean themselves in
the pilot episode morty has to shove
mega seeds up his ass we get to customs
I'm gonna need you to take these seeds
into the bathroom and I'm gonna need you
to put them way up inside your butthole
Morty but no fall right out of mine I've
done this too many times porting also
and M night some aliens Rick makes both
of them stripped down naked because
these siberian scammers are really
uncomfortable with nudity and get in the
shower right now more you
you gotta trust me morning oh and an
interdimensional cable - Jerry has to
decide whether to medically donate his
penis to save the life of an
intergalactic peace figure shrimp Lea
pitbulls life can be saved if we replace
his heart with your human penis I see
these dick jokes might have just been
for shock value in doc and Marty
but in Rick and Morty roiland has
evolved them into kind of a commentary
on this kind of universe in a sci-fi
world where all variables are possible
the only constants are simple Universal
aspects of the human experience escapist
pleasures and yes sexual anxiety okay
moving on Rick and Morty also takes more
specific inspiration from these old
channel 101 shorts in the form of
character cameos there are actually
three that I want to point out the first
is my favorite side character mr.
meeseeks so this whole idea of a genie
type task master who dissipates after
the task is completed was actually
introduced in a different doc and Marty
short where doc tells Marty about scud
the disposable assassin Marty what's the
Scotch
this choice is target connection Marty
this gun blows up itself destruction it
dies all over the place actually scud
the disposable assassin was a real life
comic book series created by Rob's Rob
in the 90s now in this short doc says
that one of the scuds only permanently
cripples its targets so that he never
gets destroyed kind of like how the
meeseeks are unable to die until jerry
improves his golf game now another
favorite character from the first season
is gazorpazorpfield the Garfield parody
cartoon that Rick and Morty watch on
interdimensional cable oh I hate my mum
and on today's you John you dumb stupid
idiots
come on gazorpazorpfield go easy on me
huh you dumb stupid weak pathetic white
white guilt now another version of the
animated Garfield already showed up in
another store that Berlin made about all
the rules trending one one videos are
allowed to break including free use of
trademarked characters hey what's up
you've been nice my friends
it's me Garfield Garfield also says a
bunch of other horrible stuff that I
probably shouldn't repeat now before I
get to that third Rick and Morty
character that originally appeared in
channel 101 shorts I want to give a
special thanks to our sponsors
Skillshare they are actually the reason
we got to make this video because we
can't do it for free
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
17,000 classes on pretty much anything
skills that we use to make these videos
like Adobe Premiere and After Effects
personally since I'm a writer and I love
analyzing story structure and the humor
of shows like Rick and Morty I got a lot
out of storytelling fundamentals
character conflict contexts and crafts
it's taught by Daniel Jose older and the
first 300 people to click on the promo
link in the description will receive a
two-month free trial to Skillshare and
all of its resources and after that it's
as low as $10 a month to continue
learning if you enjoy it or cancel it if
you don't there's no risk just check out
skl sh / new rock stars or click on the
link in the description below to get
started ok back to this third character
from roylene's old shorts probably the
most messed up character from Rick and
Morty mr. jelly bean or I should say
King jelly bean may he burn in hell now
mr. jelly bean previously showed up in a
different Justin roiland China 101 short
called unbelievable tales under the name
crumply crumple steamed and as dark as
mr. jelly bean gets on the show this guy
is even worse
so trigger warning so like mr. jelly
bean crumply was a closeted pedophile
he hosted a TV show where he told
stories about naked young boys and then
when he went home it's revealed that
he's holding real boys captive whom he
sexually assaults and mutilates
ah so yeah if Roy island was looking for
the worst creature with the least
threatening appearance to pull from his
shorts this would be the guy let's move
on from this darkness to some lighter
subtler references in Rick and Morty
episodes that call back the old shorts
so one of the most distinctive things
about Rick and Morty as a whole is the
loose improvisational style in the
dialogue Rick in Morty forever and for
over 100 years
me and Ricky morning running around and
Rick and Morty time all day long forever
a hundred days so animated shows in the
science fiction genre are normally super
precise with their dialogue and timing
so to hear Rick and the others ramble on
and stumble over their words gives this
series a sense of chaos that we've never
seen on a show before now this actually
connects back to the overall concept of
the show this is a universe where every
variable is possible so nothing matters
except the little details of the human
experience so Rick's incoherent rants
are a reflection of that humanity and of
course so is his iconic burp now this
burp is actually a callback to the dock
tomorrow pilot when roiland was
recording the audio he burped in the
middle of one of Doc's lines and decided
to just leave it in and make it part of
his character
that's right Marty something scientific
and magical will happen to him trust me
Marty and then later in the series
there's another reference when we hear
all of Rick's catchphrases and the false
memories of Total Recall yeah yeah
that's a callback to the doc and Marty
pilot just early cause Marty also doc
and Marty were supposed to make actual
cameos in the show it was gonna be in
the close Rick counters of the Rick Hein
episode but that idea was scrapped
however they did show up Where's Waldo
style in the Rick's diverse Instagram
game also if you look closely during
season two's Big Trouble in Little
Sanchez episode when tiny Rick used his
creativity to express Rick's inner cries
for help his crude drawing of Rick looks
a lot like royal in sketches of doc I'm
curious to know your thoughts do you
think Rick and Morty should return to
its roots a bit more and embrace more of
this shock value humor of doc and Marty
or do you think it's straddling the line
perfectly between this dark humor and
more complex sci-fi concepts to anybody
who might complain that this teamers -
sophomoric
to me it reflects what's most fun about
the raw independent spirit of channel
101 where creators can express the
darkest depths of their senses of humor
which allows them to stumble into these
bursts of inspiration that become
amazing shows like Rick and Morty share
your thoughts in the comments below
or with me directly on twitter @ EA boss
or with new rockstars at new rockstars
share this video and subscribe for all
of our Rick and Morty videos including
upcoming breakdown of episode 7 if you
want to help us make more videos like
this you can contribute to us on patreon
big thanks to all of our donors
especially Laurie Denning alright thanks
for watching bye